shares still has a thing or two to learn  about Twitter the 70 year old music  legend send out a controversial message  Wednesday after learning of the terror  attacks of the Istanbul Airport quote we  all pray for innocent people in Turkey  Airport the words aren't the issue here  but share tacked on the bomb and  explosion emojis to the end of her tweet  and that's what fans took issue with the  Istanbul attacks have taken the lives of  a 42 victims at so far after the  backlash shared deleted the tweet then  posted this one quote no excuse I'm use  to using emoji to help say more than 140  letters sorry chair then went silent on  Twitter coming back briefly only to  share this post no tweets today cuz  wanted to think about sensitivity meant  no disrespect but that's not enough down  a few pegs is okay